♫ Feminists don't have a sense of humor. ♫
♫ Feminists just want to be alone -- boo hoo, hoo, hoo. ♫
♫ Feminists spread vicious lies and rumors. ♫
♫ They have a tumor on their funny bone. ♫
♫ They say child molestation isn't funny -- ha, ha, ha, ha. ♫
♫ Rape and degradation's just a crime -- lighten up, ladies. ♫
♫ Rampant prostitution's sex for money -- what’s wrong with that? ♫
♫ Can't these chicks do anything but whine? ♫
♫ Dance break! Da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da. ♫
♫ Da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da. ♫
♫ Woo-hoo! ♫
♫ Da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da -- ♫
♫ yeah, take it off. ♫
♫ Da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, dum. ♫
♫ They say cheap objectification isn’t witty -- it’s hot! ♫
♫ Equal work and wages worth the fight -- ♫
♫ sing us a new one. ♫
♫ On-demand abortion every city -- OK, but no gun control. ♫
♫ Won’t these women ever get a life? ♫
♫ Feminists don’t have a sense of humor -- poor Hillary. ♫
♫ Feminists and vegetarians -- make mine a Big Mac. ♫
♫ Feminists spread vicious lies and rumors. ♫
♫ They're far too sensitive to ever be a ham, ♫
♫ that's why these feminists just need to find a man. ♫
♫ Da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da. ♫
I’m Dennis Kucinich and I approved this message.
Thank you.
(Applause)
I asked my mother, you know, should I say anything in support of anyone?
And she said, "Oh no! Just dis everybody, except Ralph Nader."
(Laughter)
♫ I could show the world how to smile, ♫
♫ I could be glad all of the while. ♫
♫ I could turn the gray skies to blue, if I had you. ♫
♫ I could leave the old days behind, ♫
♫ leave all my pals, I’d never mind. ♫
♫ I could start my life all anew, if I had you. ♫
♫ I could climb the snow-capped mountains, ♫
♫ sail the mighty ocean wide. ♫
♫ I could cross the burning desert, if I had you by my side. ♫
♫ I could be a king, dear, uncrowned, humble or poor, rich or renowned. ♫
♫ There is nothing I couldn’t do, if I had you. ♫
Thank you. Well, thank you so much.